[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean jacques carrière est né à
colombières sur orb en 1931 il est mort
cette année elle a été enterrée dans le
même village de la maison qui l'a vu
naître au cimetière où il est maintenant
terré il disait qu'il aurait donc
parcouru 150 m il a beaucoup voyagé
regardez le monde pour le raconter il a
écrit des histoires pour pierre et ex 12
bunuel
peter brook louis malle jacques deray
milos forman marco ferreri philippe de
broca volker schlöndorff jean luc godard
carlos a aura andrzej wajda la guiza
oshima philip kaufman philippe garrel
jean paul rappeneau johnattan graser
atiq rahimi julian schnabel
sans parler toutes ses pièces de théâtre
des textes très important contre la
controverse de valladolid sont adaptés à
son adaptation légendaire du mahabharata
ou de ses traductions et de ses livres
c'était pas toujours très facile d'être
l'ami de jean claude carrière
une fois j'étais en vacances je les
appelais jeudi jean-claude venise est
formidable il ya la lagune ya les
bateaux y aller musée lui il m'a dit
qu'est ce tu fais je les écoute je suis
là je regarde le paysage fantastique il
m'a dit tu fous rien oui j'ai discuté en
jean claude je rentre à paris pour
travailler sur le carrière était très
fier d'être un scénariste il me disait
que la meilleure décision qu'il avait
prise dans sa vie était de ne jamais
avoir réalisé deux films ce qui devait
permis de travailler tout au long de sa
vie il a d'ailleurs été le premier
scénariste à avoir droit à une
rétrospective au moma new york à deux
ans juste après avoir reçu un oscar
d'honneur le jour de sa mort j'ai mangé
son plat favori qui est une brouillade
aux asperges sauvages que jusqu'à 10 par
philippe barthez son filleul et en
mangeant les asperges et penser merde
mon ami est mort j'ai pensé en
plus il sait même pas qu'il est mort
jean claude carrière savait tout sur
tout qu'est ce qui va lui dire à lui
qu'il est mort après tout ce qui m'a
appris j'aurais pu lui apprendre ça je
crois que nous perdons un grand esprit
c'était un grand honneur pour moi de
l'avoir connu j'embrasse n'allait chiara
et je te salue jean claude
oui
[Applaudissements]